c'est l'image politique de la semaine
pour la première fois depuis 1918 les
députés à l'unisson ont entamé la
Marseillais ont entonné la Marseillaise
mardi à l'Assemblée nationale madame
monsieur bonjour c'est donc avec cette
image rarissime que nous ouvrons ce
numéro de La voix est Libre en Bourgogne
6 jours après la mobilisation tout aussi
historique des Français à la suite des
attentats qui ont fait 17 victimes dans
les locaux de Charlie Hebdo à Montrouge
et dans le supermarché casher de la
Porte de Vincennes que va-t-il rester de
cette union nationale la France est en
guerre a dit le Premier ministre mais
comment lutter efficacement contre le
terrorisme tout en s'attaquant à
l'antisémitisme indispermophobie et au
racisme comment éviter les amalgames et
bien pour en débattre nous avons réuni
sur ce plateau avec kerabouziane bonjour
bonjour vous êtes députés socialiste de
Côte-d'Or vous faites notamment partie
du gros d'études République et religions
qui se réunit peu mais qui aura
peut-être vocation à plus se réunir dans
l'avenir Guillaume l'arrivée député UMP
de l'Yonne bonjour bonjour vous allez
signer l'an dernier un rapport sur la
lutte contre l'apologie du terrorisme
notamment sur Internet on verra ça
Emmanuel Masson bonjour vous êtes
secrétaire académique du SNPDEN donc le
Syndicat national des personnels de
direction de l'éducation nationale et
moi cette affaire cree bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le président du conseil
régional du culte musulman en Bourgogne
bonjour à tous et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à la maison je vous
rappelle que vous pouvez réagir ou poser
vos questions sur notre site internet
bourgogne.france 3.fr sur Twitter
hashtag lvl Bourgogne Watt F3 Bourgogne
ou sur notre page Facebook alors un beau
d'abord sur cette image que l'on a vu en
début d'émission sur cette unité
nationale symbolisée donc par cette
marseillaise par ses applaudissements de
part et d'autre des bancs de l'Assemblée
nationale comment vous avez vécu tout
simplement vous tous les deux vous qui
êtes des représentants
je crois que les hommes et les femmes
politiques ont entendu le message que
les Français nos concitoyens au sens
large nous ont donné dimanche dernier et
je crois que lors de la mobilisation
historique et je crois que nous ne
devons pas nous n'avons pas le droit à
l'erreur et c'était aussi pour leur
montrer que nous avons pris la mesure de
la situation et que nous sommes tous
mobilisés sur tous les bancs de
l'Assemblée pour faire de notre
République une république de du droit et
une république du mieux vivre ensemble
il y a le temps de l'émotion le temps de
l'hommage et c'est vrai que dans
l'hémicycle mardi ça c'est matérialisé
par cette tel en collectif qui
consistait pour la première fois en
effet depuis depuis quasiment un siècle
est-ce que tous les tous les députés
quel que soit la couleur de leurs banc
en tonne ensemble la Marseillaise mais
après le temps de de l'hommage il faut
entrer évidemment dans le temps de de
l'action nous avons un devoir d'union et
de voir d'unité mais nous avons tout
autant et nous allons parler dans cette
émission à devoir d'efficacité
Emmanuel Masson a beaucoup parlé de
quelques incidents mais il y en a quand
même eu quelques dizaines en France dans
les établissements scolaires notamment
lors de la minute de silence est-ce que
malgré tout dans la grande majorité ce
sentiment d'unité nationale après ce qui
s'est passé après évalue dans les
établissements d'après ce que vous en
dit tous vos collègues je crois que
effectivement la première chose qu'il
faut dire c'est que on a médiatisé des
incidents mais que dans la grande
majorité des cas l'émotion nationale a
été partagée dans les établissements
scolaires c'est toujours un point un peu
délicat d'organiser comme ça le
président de la République a décrété de
national mercredi soir et donc on a
retrouvé les élèves le jeudi matin il
fallait organiser avec les enseignants
qui étaient eux-mêmes dans l'émotion
mais qui se sont formidablement
mobilisés et organisés débattre avec les
élèves mais on a vu de très belles
choses je vous disais notamment des
chaînes humaines dans un lycée qu'on m'a
raconté de 400 élèves et enseignants en
formant je suis Charlie donc il faut
avant tout mettre en avant cette
cohésion autour de ce drame même s'il
faut pas occulter quelques incidents on
y reviendra Mustapha immédiatement aller
la plupart des IMAP des associations
musulmanes ont dénoncé ses attentats
vous même vous allez participer à des
rassemblements est-ce que c'était
nécessité vraiment de s'inscrire dans
cette unité nationale surtout que les
terroristes se réclamaient d'un certain
Islam
c'était une nécessité pour plusieurs
raisons d'avoir en tant que citoyen on
se voit mal se mettre à l'écart alors
qu'il y a
un attentat qui frappe la nation ensuite
c'était une nécessité parce que les
auteurs de cette attentat on prononcé
des mots des phrases qui ont qui sont de
nature à
créer l'amalgame dans certains esprits
il fallait dire tout de suite pourquoi
ces gens là ne pouvaient pas s'exprimer
au nom de l'islam not in my name
d'ailleurs on a vu un souvent cette
pancarte dans le monde entier voilà donc
c'était très important et puis
il fallait à la fois rassurer la
communauté musulmane qui qui de fait à
l'écran les amalgames les conséquences
dans le sa vie quotidienne mais aussi
rassurer nos concitoyens et le rappeler
que leur concitoyens de confession
musulmane les aiment la France aiment la
la famille le travail tout ce à quoi
nous sommes tous attachés et ça c'est
très important je crois que tout le
monde a vu aussi ce Lassana Bathily ce
jeune homme qui devient presque un
symbole en ce moment puisqu'il va être
il est malien il va être naturalisé
français il est musulmans ils
travaillent dans un supermarché casher
et c'est lui qui a sauvé un certain
nombre de personnes le jour de la prise
d'otage vendredi dernier porte de
Vincennes et il y a une question d'un
téléspectateur Arthur qui nous a posé
cette question là sur notre site on a vu
le jeune employé du supermarché cacher
qui est donc un musulman est-ce que
c'est pas la preuve que la plupart des
gens vivent finalement ensemble et qu'on
regarde trop les exceptions est-ce que
c'est Monsieur l'arrivée il faut dire
des choses avec beaucoup de clarté nous
avons un ennemi qui nous a déclaré la
guerre cet ennemi c'est l'islamisme
radical armée nous l'avons dit le
Premier ministre l'a dit solennellement
également nous avons un ennemi qui est
l'islamisme radical armé le djihadisme
nous avons évidemment des amis
parmi l'immense majoritaire des
musulmans de France qui sont nos
compatriotes et qui ont le droit de
vivre paisiblement comme tous les
Français et qui ont aussi le devoir
comme le président du conseil régional
du culte musulman la fait
qui ont le devoir de s'exprimer pour
expliquer qu'en effet l'islam et
l'islamisme ça n'est pas la même chose
qu'en effet l'islam des lumières au fond
cette Islam modérée est pleinement
compatible avec la République voilà je
crois qu'il y a aussi un devoir de
pédagogie un devoir d'expression et
j'étais très heureux je veux en
remercier le président du conseil
régional du culte musulman j'étais très
heureux de constater que dans la plupart
des mosquées de France vendredi un appel
commun a été élu c'est absolument
fondamental qui est une unité aussi qui
s'exprime pour dire les choses très
clairement l'islam de France et
pleinement respectueux des lois de la
République et au fond combat lui aussi
l'islamisme radical en gros il est il
est important de remettre les pendules à
l'heure le président Hollande l'a fait
lui aussi d'ailleurs c'était jeudi la
profité d'une visite à l'Institut du
monde arabe en disant que les premières
victimes du fanatisme du fondamentalisme
et de l'intolérance mais ce sont les
musulmans c'était important de faire
cette remise en perspective bien sûr
d'autant plus que monsieur kerkri l'a
dit nos concitoyens parce que je n'aime
pas parler de communauté musulmane il
n'y a pas il n'y a qu'une communauté
c'est la communauté nationale nos
concitoyens
musulmans ont très mal vécu ce qui s'est
passé le drame était horrible et ils ont
très vite senti que dans certains
esprits il risquaient d'y avoir un
amalgame et c'était important aussi
qu'il montre que il n'adhère pas à
cette Islam là d'ailleurs je moi je le
disais lors de certaines rencontres que
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire pendant
cette période
ils sont les premières victimes après
après Charlie et mon rouge et
et la porte de Vincennes
qui ont été bien sûr les Juifs les Juifs
de France et d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs il
n'y a pas à opposer toutes les victimes
méritent que qu'on leur rende hommage
mais aussi la longue de choc qui qui
risque de et elle s'exprime il y a des
lieux de culte juifs qui ont été
profanées mais aussi beaucoup de lieux
de culte musulmans qui ont été attaqués
et c'était important que le Président de
la République rappelle que comme la fée
d'ailleurs le premier ministre jamais
aucun juif ne doit avoir peur mais aussi
jamais aucun musulman ne doit ni avoir
peur ni avoir honte de ce que d'autres
au nom de leur religion
vous me tendez la perche je vais vous
propose dans les établissements
scolaires il y a eu des discussions
entamées un petit peu partout avec les
élèves à ce propos je voudrais vous
faire écouter un échange qui s'est
déroulé au lycée Montchapet de Dijon
c'était donc cette semaine entre un
professeur et ses élèves qui explique
leur réactions après les attentats en
écoute nous comme on est musulman tout
d'abord quand on a vu ça on a eu honte
après
après on s'est senti mal parce que parce
que les gens
on a eu peur qu'il fasse la différence
entre les terroristes et les musulmans
qui passent la malgave tu veux dire et
que ma mère elle a eu peur ce que vous
venez d'entendre de la part de votre
camarade qui est donc d'Orion musulmane
c'est quelque chose qu'on a assez peu
perçu c'est-à-dire la réaction la
communauté musulmane la peur des
musulmans dans ces jours là qui ont
suivi c'est-à-dire que à la fois
effectivement la honte et puis la peur
d'être stigmatisé traiter déjà qu'en
France vous savez qu'on est dans un pays
où les discriminations existent et quand
après les gens vont aller dire vivement
qu'on les fasse dégager etc bah non ça
c'est pas la France moi aussi étant
musulman dans le Coran c'est écrit comme
quoi tu es une personne c'est tuer toute
l'humanité
la honte puis la peur indisait la
première jeune fille dans le journal
régional hier soir on a encore entendu
des musulmans dire leur solidarité à la
fois leur peur d'aller à la mosquée même
alors c'est le cas aussi pour les Juifs
de France comment on va faire pour
lutter contre ça et pour ressouder la
nation vous il y a une solution à ça on
a l'impression que c'est des discours
contient depuis des dizaines d'années
maintenant en France vous avez raison de
de souligner que notre détermination
elle doit aussi être assez modeste parce
qu'il y a une faillite il y a eu des
erreurs et elle est paressante il y a eu
en effet dans dans les décennies qui
sont écoulés sans doute des choses qui
ont été ratées
la directrice départementale des
services de l'éducation nationale de
l'Yonne madame Annie Partouche m'a
téléphoné cette semaine au députés pour
me dire qu'en effet même dans l'Yonne il
y avait eu des incidents bien sûr il y a
une immense majorité des élèves
grâce et avec au fond les maîtres
d'école les professeurs sur rendre
hommage aux victimes mais il y a aussi à
Sens à Auxerre même à Toucy au cœur de
la Puisaye des élèves qui n'ont pas au
fond communier dans cette élan national
et donc je pense que ça doit nous
remettre en cause la morale civique
l'apprentissage des règles de la
République la laïcité comme distinction
du temporel et du spirituel le dialogue
entre les religions toutes choses qui
doivent en effet être apprises peut-être
un peu mieux encore dans les écoles et
dans les collèges sans oublier et je
m'arrête là que la France a une histoire
que la France a une histoire
chronologique et que le fond nous avons
avec le XVIIIe siècle et les lumières
mais aussi naturellement la fidélité à
nos racines chrétiennes et à la
sécularisation qui a été entraînée aussi
au fil des années nous avons aussi une
histoire et nous n'avons pas à nous
excuser d'être ce que nous sommes
monsieur et ensuite madame vous aime
premièrement je pense que il faut se
garder de certaines idées fausses qui
commencent à mon sens à être un petit
peu avancé l'école ne découvre les
écoles au sens large ne découvraient pas
ces problèmes il faut se rappeler quand
même que il y a pas si longtemps mars
2012 c'est les attentats de Toulouse et
de Montauban notamment contre une école
juive et que on était dans le même cas
de figure d'émotion nationale dans la
même demande de recueillement de
l'institution j'allais dire d'autant
plus évidente que trois élèves avaient
perdu la vie dans cette attentat et dès
ce moment là nous avons vu dans les
établissements un certain nombre de
réactions contraire aux valeurs de la
République
en l'occurrence qui visait la communauté
juive donc l'école elle s'est intéressée
depuis longtemps à ces questions je
voudrais quand même rappeler notre
organisation syndicale a porté ses
valeurs de l'électricité à saluer la loi
sur l'interdiction du des symboles
religieux de 2004 qui a pacifié la vie
des établissements scolaires la question
que l'on se pose maintenant c'est est-ce
que la la papacifié en surface mais elle
nous a quand même beaucoup apporté et
l'éducation nationale c'est emparée
depuis longtemps de ces questions là je
voudrais citer quand même et c'était la
précédente la précédente nom nature ce
qui a été fait autour de la Charte de la
laïcité
donc qui est quand même très important
enfin là c'est Vincent payant en
l'occurrence sur la voie de refondation
et le nouvel enseignement de la morale
civique qui va se mettre en oeuvre en
septembre 2015 à la rentrée a été décidé
là aussi dans la loi de retournation
avant les événements donc il faut se
dire bien qu'on est là-dessus mais que
la difficulté aujourd'hui elle est de
réinterroger nos modes de transmission
pour qu'effectivement on la puisse la
faire partager par la totale de totalité
de la communauté éducative
la Troisième République c'est principaux
ont été fondés je suis le député de sœur
et je suis le lointain successeur de
Paul Bert tout ça était en réalité
pensée fondée et crie dans la loi de la
République dès les débuts de la de la
troisième il y a une continuité je pense
aussi à Jean-Pierre Chevènement quand on
était mise de l'éducation dans les
années 84 86 faut faire vivre cela et au
fond en réalité une idée toute simple
que les générations les plus nouvelles
des enfants aujourd'hui de France qui
ont 10 12 13 14 ans intègre aussi
complètement ce socle républicain
qui est beaucoup interrogée qui va être
sollicité prochainement et et il ne faut
pas l'oublier la caisse de résonance de
la société les enfants que l'on
accueille dans nos écoles ce sont des
enfants qui vivent dans des familles qui
entendent des choses qui sont soumis un
certain nombre de
médias qui vont chercher les
informations et donc je crois que on
peut on peut attendre beaucoup de
l'école mais il faut aussi que en dehors
de l'école il y a aussi un
accompagnement à la citoyenneté au sens
large ça passe aussi par vous monsieur
kerkri et par les associations
musulmanes qui qui sont très nombreuses
dans le pays
alors ce que je trouve un peu gênant
dans le nom dit quand on parle des
incidents à l'école c'est que en
laissant entendre que c'est ces jeunes
élèves sont tous de confession musulmane
et qu'ils sont éduqués dans des familles
musulmanes sur des valeurs musulmanes et
donc on demande de responsables
musulmans
de parier de régler cela
n'est pas forcément le cas ce n'est pas
forcément le cas ça c'est la première
chose néanmoins
les responsables musulmans sont
volontaires pour apporter leur pierre à
l'édifice de l'éducation nationale
notamment par les
aumôneries de l'enseignement
auxquels j'appelle parce que il faut
reconnaître à l'élève aux jeunes sa
dimension spirituelle
et lui permettre un accompagnant
spirituel responsable ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose les
quelques dizaines on a dit 200
d'incidents dans les établissements
scolaires rapportés au 12 millions
d'élèves
qu'est-ce que c'est ça quel pourcentage
ça représente les 3 millions et demi à 4
millions de citoyens qui sont sortis de
dans la rue dimanche dans cette
formidable et historique est en de
solidarité et d'unités de fraternité ne
représente pas beaucoup plus que 5 %
rapporté à l'ensemble de des citoyens
français donc il faut pas relativiser
mais faire la part des choses
mais moi je reviens en fait que il faut
savoir que le
l'Office musulman là où l'imam donne
l'enseignement hebdomadaire à la
communauté les élèves sont à l'école et
les élèves de confession musulmane ne
viennent jamais à l'office officiel dans
les mosquées sauf pendant les vacances
scolaires et c'est très peu dans l'année
ou alors et la majorité denture d'entre
eux n'ont pas une éducation religieuse
dans les maisons comme on le comprendre
donc on a un travail à faire mais en
même temps il faut
raisons garder quand on parle des
incidents de l'éducation et des rapports
des religions à cette éducation et pour
ajouter à vos propos il y a Ali qui nous
écrit aussi on a marre d'être considéré
comme un risque que par ce qu'on est
arabe moi je suis d'origine maghrébine
mais je suis d'abord français et je n'ai
pas de religion je suis athée pourquoi
ne parle-t-on jamais de nous Emmanuel
maçon vouliez dire réagir première rôle
d'un chef d'établissement dans des
circonstances comme celle-là c'est
d'assurer la cohésion au sein de son
établissement la cohésion de la totalité
de la population et de ses élèves et par
exemple j'ai eu un témoignage d'une
collègue qui me disait que de jeunes
élèves un petit peu dans l'esprit de ce
qu'on voyait au lycée de Montchapet
avait exprimé la crainte d'être expulsé
crainte totalement irrationnelle mais
que l'on peut comprendre dans les
circonstances donc on a ce rôle là de
rassurer les incidents je crois qu'il
faut qu'on dise il y a eu deux types au
fond d'incident il y a eu des incidents
qui ont troublé l'ordre de
l'établissement scolaire par des
manifestations excessives bruyantes voir
par des départs d'élèves au moment de la
minute de silence et ils doivent être
sanctionnés dans l'esprit du règlement
intérieur et puis il y a des expressions
qui se sont faits dans le calme qui
devaient travailler de manière éducative
les premières aussi mais pour intégrer
effectivement les valeurs de la
République
je suis sûr que c'est une position
partagée par chacun même s'il y avait un
seul incident on dit 200 madame Belkacem
en effet donner ce chiffre mardi
lorsqu'elle était interrogée par le
député Claude guzzegen même s'il y avait
un seul incident la force de cet
incident ne doit pas être sous-estimé et
je pense vraiment que notre
responsabilité encore une fois je sais
qu'elle est partagée mais notre
responsabilité c'est de traiter ce
problème très sérieusement et très
concrètement dans chaque classe dans
chaque classe dans chaque école dans
chaque commune
blasphème c'est ce genre de choses qu'il
faut rappeler aux élèves et leur
s'interroger sur ce qui a failli en
effet et c'est forcé d'être le plus
concret possible dans l'apprentissage de
de l'histoire de de France dans la
compréhension de ce que sont les lois de
notre République dans la fermeté qui
doit être celle de l'État de droit face
à certaines menaces mais aussi il faut
expliquer que la laïcité ce n'est pas le
rejet de toute dimension spirituelle
c'est aussi le droit pour chacun de
pratiquer son culte librement tout ça
est extrêmement difficile je veux pas
surtout qu'on se paye de mots je
sous-estime pas la difficulté qui doit
être celle du maître d'école face à une
classe parfois sans doute difficile à
après demander parce que l'école est pas
complètement
imperméable à ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur tout ça est très compliqué
on voit bien quand même que notre pays
est fragile aujourd'hui et l'éducation
nationale à du coup une responsabilité
absolument absolument majeur aujourd'hui
dans les mois qui viennent dans les
années qui viennent parce qu'il faut
bien voir c'est aussi un effort très
très très très long pour au fond
reconsolider notre nation
car déjà
le président de mon groupe à l'Assemblée
nationale elle dit une phrase que je
trouve très juste on n'a pas de leçon à
donner aujourd'hui on a que de les
leçons à prendre et concernant
concernant l'école bien sûr ne jamais
minimiser un fait quel qu'il soit au
sein de d'une enceinte qui est là pour
éduquer en plus de instruire mais
l'école seule ne fera pas tout le
travail je l'ai déjà dit et il faut que
l'on est aussi les moyens pour que cela
fonctionne et j'ai été agréablement
surprise par
le porte-parole de l'opposition à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui on est
tous unis autour de cette de
ce moment de cet objectif où il a
reparlé des hussards de la République et
j'ai été ravi d'entendre revenir et
redonner à nos enseignants qui parfois
sont malmenés il faut le reconnaître
malmener dans la reconnaissance de leur
de leurs fonctions mais parfois par les
moyens dont il ne disposent pas souvent
parfois ou qui sont pas adaptés et donc
je crois beaucoup à l'action
mon collègue en a parlé et et c'est tout
le travail que nous aurons amené très
prochainement
Emmanuel Macron dans la deuxième partie
sur la présence des religions au sein de
l'école je pense qu'elle est importante
mais sur la formation des enseignants
quand même parce que moi j'ai participé
avec le recteur à la consultation des
organisations syndicales et les
enseignants ont été bien entendu présent
je crois qu'il y a un sentiment unanime
des enseignants des chefs
d'établissement sur la nécessaire
formation à la laïcité sur ce tronc
commun sur ce socle des valeurs que non
pas reçu les étudiants lorsqu'ils
étaient dans une formation disciplinaire
et c'est pour ça quand même qu'on a
salué le retour de la formation initiale
des enseignants qui est extrêmement
importante les enseignants le disent
quelque chose très concrète moi je suis
pour que l'autorité des maîtres déconne
l'autorité des professeurs soit
réaffirmés y compris dans les classes
avec une idée un peu de de verticalité
c'est le maître qui transmet qui donne
des leçons pour le coup aux élèves et
par exemple il y a aussi des symboles
moi je suis tout à fait favorable à ce
que les élèves se lèvent avant chaque
leçon dans une classe c'est un simple
fait encore je suis ça c'est plus ou
moins fait plus ou moins pas fait du
tout bon ça dépend ça dépend je suis
favorable
du ministre de l'éducation nationale
donne cela au professeur je pense c'est
important je pense que nous pouvons
aussi avoir une réflexion je l'avais
engagée il y a près de deux ans à
l'Assemblée nationale avec quelques
collègues sur sur la question de de
l'uniforme à l'école pas un uniforme
militaire naturellement ça revient le
débat mais au fond et c'est pas non plus
la nostalgie de la blouse grise mais au
fond l'idée que y est un symbole à la
fois d'égalité et d'appartenance qui
gomme les différences sociales qui gomme
les différences et qui affirme au fond
dans un établissement et social des
couleurs partagées moi je trouve c'est
une idée intéressante il faut qu'on soit
à la fois chez un monsieur très très
ferme très clair dans nos principes et
puis peut-être que dans des actes
symboliques très concrets on fasse un
peu aussi bouger les bouger les lignes
notamment concernant l'école justement
un seul mot
toutes les écoles ne se ressemblent pas
non plus et il faut encourager donner
les moyens à celles qui en ont le plus
besoin parce qu'on a des problématiques
sur certains territoires qui ne sont pas
les mêmes que celles de certains
établissements plus plus favorisés et ça
il faut qu'on y pense aussi raison je
suis très préoccupé cet égard du choix
qui est fait par la ministre actuelle de
l'éducation nationale de gommer
certaines zones d'éducation prioritaire
j'ai ça très concrètement ce moment où
ça dans peut-être le quartier le plus
difficile de la ville qui s'appelle le
quartier de la rive droite qui sort du
dispositif d'éducation prioritaire il
faut je pense sur ces affaires de Zep
restait assez cohérent et concentré des
efforts dans les quartiers comme dans le
plus besoin
on va
s'interrompre quelques minutes puisqu'il
va être midi dans 15 secondes donc c'est
l'heure de jeter un coup d'oeil sur
l'information régionale à la mi-journée
ce samedi et aujourd'hui le flash vous
est présenté par liseré on se retrouve
juste après pour parler notamment de la
lutte contre le terrorisme parce qu'on
est encore pas abordé cette question à
tout de suite